[Music]
let's talk about securing your software
supply chain
first things first what do we even mean
when we say the term software supply
chain
regardless of the scale of software and
services that you ship it all starts
with your developers writing code
the code they write eventually becomes
the applications that are accessed by
your users
the software supply chain then is a set
of systems and processes that are used
to get this code from development all
the way to production and to your users
this includes more than just your code
but also things like your builds your
packaging scripts your dependencies
and dependencies can be especially
tricky because if you use external
dependencies each of those also has its
own software supply chain
the whole of these systems and processes
can be complex with many moving pieces
that reference not just your code but
everything that could possibly affect it
this complexity opens up opportunities
for bad actors to compromise your
software's integrity
if you cannot verify explicitly that the
code you run has not been tampered with
your customers are at a greater risk and
you can lose trust in your business
securing your software supply chain is a
holistic approach that's focused on
applying principles and practices to
protect your software's integrity
the systems and processes we need to
apply this strategy to generally fall
across four key stages of the software
supply chain
code build store and deploy your
software supply chain starts in the
beginning of the first stage in your
software's lifecycle writing source code
this is when developers write code and
tests in ides on their workstation
once they've completed functionality
such as features or bug fixes within
their code they'll usually push to a
remote source code management system
new code changes pushed to these systems
usually trigger the next stage building
a deployable artifact
typically this process is automated and
the build runs as a unit of work across
some set of workers
and those workers do things like run
tests pull in external dependencies and
produce an artifact such as a container
image
once this deployable artifact is
produced it's then pushed to long-term
storage like a registry
your pre-production and production
environments have access to pull
artifacts from here
these environments know when to fetch
these artifacts based on pipelines that
orchestrate their rollout through the
practice of continuous deployment for
continuous delivery
across these stages are intertwined it
systems and human processes each of
which can be vulnerable to potential
attacks from bad actors
history gives us examples of these types
of attacks that can occur across these
stages
bad actors can attempt to write
malicious code or code that is subject
to vulnerabilities like sql injection
and push this to the company's source
code management system
they can also inject malicious
instructions into build pipelines which
they can run as arbitrary and untrusted
scripts or they can even build artifacts
from other malicious source code that
isn't yours
with external dependencies bad actors
can access vulnerabilities intransitive
dependencies or even take advantage of
dependency confusion by either typo
squatting or compromising the latest
version of a package
even if actors are not able to access
your source code management systems or
your build execution platform
should they have access to your artifact
storage they can then build their own
malicious artifacts out of band and push
them to that storage
and because the storage is how your
environments access artifacts that must
be run
actors can now reference these bad
artifacts in ci cd pipelines that are
ultimately responsible for your
software's deployment
across all of these scenarios are also
network perimeters and infrastructure
that must be secured
with multiple attack vectors along every
step of the way software supply chain
security must be a holistic effort at
every single stage
security can no longer be only a focus
of where your production code runs
to practice software supply chain
security you must shift security left
across the entire software supply chain
as early as when your developers start
writing code on their workstations
best practices can be pushed left into
the developer experience such as
securing workstations and providing
in-context vulnerability scanning
and building both automated policy
checks and human review into the code
review process
this can extend to the build stage as
well with practices such as
automatically generating a software bill
of materials to document what
dependencies are used
starting with secure defaults like
providing a standard and minimal base
image for containers
all while ensuring that build
configurations are auditable treated and
reviewed as code
as that code begins to flow through the
stages of your software's life cycle
it is also important to establish the
authenticity of what is produced at
every stage
this means explicitly providing proof
that an artifact came from a specific
source repository and was built in a
specific environment
[Music]
this proof should be used further down
the software supply chain for a couple
of reasons
you can continue to add details about
the artifact to this proof from checks
such as vulnerability scans and artifact
repositories
and you can also enforce policies around
this proof automatically at deploy time
this enables you to maintain trust all
the way through admission into your
production environment and can also
enable you to go one step further
and perform continuous runtime scanning
this process of establishing verifiable
and maintainable trust is one that must
flow seamlessly across multiple stages
of the supply chain
this practice can look like creating
crypto signed attestations that prove
that artifacts were indeed built from a
trusted source repository in a trusted
build environment
and were scanned for vulnerabilities by
a trusted party
all with the ability to define auditable
declarative policy that controls whether
or not these artifacts
are admitted into an environment based
on these attestations
[Music]
finally across all these stages a secure
software supply chain that implements
these practices will not only have
discovery of potential compromises but
the means to remediate issues quickly by
pushing updated build configurations or
updated policies through code review
as software supply chain security
continues to evolve and develop we
recommend reviewing salsa which stands
for supply chain levels for software
artifacts
this end-to-end framework provides a
rubric to help you determine what level
of software supply chain security you
have implemented
as you begin to strengthen your software
supply chain security salsa is helpful
in that each level makes incremental
jumps to an ideal end state with
actionable steps you can take to get
from level to level
the optimal goal for a secure software
supply chain is to pair the salsa
framework with rigorous vulnerability
detection and remediation processes
to learn more about how google cloud can
help strengthen your software supply
chain security check out
cloud.google.com
software supply dash chain dash security
and stay tuned for more thank
[Music]